T THVOTES AS EARLY AS YO
N PAITS DUE AND AGE WITH
ALL OF YOU.
BIG, BREAKG NEWS OUTF THE
SHINON SWAMP
ATONGRSWOMAN
ALANDRIA OCASIO-RTEZ IS
FORMAL UND HOUSE FIXING THE
STATN WHILE TAILOF THE
PROBHAVEOTEEN RELEASED.
LAST YEAR OCAS-CORZ WAS ALSOUNDR
ATTENDANCE DATMET LLUP FOR
ACCEING AND, WELL,
IMPEISSIBLE GIFT TUGIT'S
NOCLEAR IF TOD'S NEWS IS
RELAD TO THE PREVIOUSCOMPLAINWEE
REBLICS ARE MONG AHEADWITHHEIR O
DENSELF-INFLICTED SASTERSINCLUDD
R FELLOW AMERINS BIN
EMY NES IN AFGHANIAN.
ONE OFHEIGGE DEBACLES AMERICAN .
USE PUBLICANS LAUNING A
PROBE TO T DISASTROUS
THDRAWAL.THEY ARE VOWINTRANAREND
ACCOUNTABITY INTO HOW THE
BIDEN ADMISTRATION FAILED AT
SUCH AEVEL.
HERE WITH  REACTN, HSE
ERSIT COMMITTEE CHRMAN
RANKG NUER REPUBLICAN
CONGSSMAN JAS COMER.
AT'S KEY.
WEAVEN'T TALKED A LOT ABOUT
THE ORIGINS OF COVID.WILL THAT >
WE'VE EN MEETING WITH E
STEENG COMMITTEE, MMITE
AIRSND OTHER CMITTEES.
SOME TYPE  JURISDICTION.
THAT WILL BE PRIORITY, NOT
JUST THE ORIGINSF COVISOME
OF T DISIO THAT WERE MAD
WEANT  BRING IN AN INTERVIEWALLN
TOLD DR. FCIHAT THIS I
VIOUY A LAB LEAK.
THIS IOBVISLY MAMADE
EN TY CHANGE THEIRTORY
WEATEREARNED THRGH SOME
OUR INSTIGATIVE WORK THAT NY
THE SCIENTISTS THATAV
UCI  LINK ECTO GO ALONG
TH ERYTHING, THEY RE
CEIVG GRTS FM THE NIH.
HAD A LOT  HELFROM THE CDC.
INVESTATE T.
WE WANT TOINVESTIGE TH.
GHANTAN, NO ONE KNOWS WHOMADE T.
THESE E SPLIBIG
INVEIGATIONS WE'REOINGO
FOCUON.>> Sean:E EXCT ELON MUSK
IS GOING TO HAVENOTHER
DISCLOSURE AS LATETO
HE SAID IF Y SHUOWN ANY
DIENTI VOICES, THAT'THE
VEEFINITION OF ELECTION
INTERFENCE.
TALKED OUT THE MEDIA BEG
MPLIT IN HOW TTTERAS THE
AROF THE DEMOCRAC PAY.
G REVELAONS.
YORE GOINGO BE LEADI THE
VESTIGATION IN THE BIDENS,
JOE DEIN PARTICULAR.
YOSAID THIWILL BE AN
INVESTIGATN ABOUT THEPRESIDT HI.
LET'S LK AUT THAT.JOE BIDEN LIEE
NEVESPOKE WITH HIS FAMY ORHUNTEN
SINESS DEALING
THE IS EVIDENCE TO THECONTRARY,C
WE KNOW OFT AST  MTINGS
THAT JOE ATTDED WI HIS SON
HUNTER AND HISOREIGN BUSINESS
PARTNERS.
THQUESTION I IF,N FA,
JOE BIN BENEFITED FINCIALLY,
WH IS THE PROPERERM FOR
THAT
IS THAT PAY TO PLAY?
IS TT, YOU KW, SELLING
ACCESST THE HIGHEST VEL?
>> N
FALY WAS ACTING  FORGN
ENTS
WE HE A RM FOR TT IN
WASHINGTON, C.
WE CALTHAT LBYIS
WE KNOW E BIN LIED ABOUTIS
KNOWLEDGE OF HUNTER AND JIM'S
SHADBUSINESS DEALIS.
WE KNOW TH JOE LIED ABT HI
PARTICIPATN INHOSE BUSINESS
ALIN.
YOU'VE ALREADDOCUMENTED,
AN, HE HADEVERAL MEETINGS
WITH PEOPLTHAT DURING THE
CAAIGNE SAID HNEVEMETWITH.
HAD MEETINGS ON AIR FOE O,
MEETIN IN E WHITE HOUSE.
THERE IS CORREONDENCE WHE
OPLEN HUNTER'SAPTOAND
THE AILS AND TEXT MESSAGESAY
ENJOYED MEETG YOURAD.
I THINIS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
OPEN SOMDOORS FOUS.
JOBIDEN WAS AN AIVE AYER
SOE LI ABOUT THAT, HE LIED
ABOUT THE PTOP
YOGO BACK TO THE DEBATAND
THAT'S WHAT SO GOOD ABT WH
ELON MUSK S TURNED OR THE
BUAR, JOE BIDEN ID IN E
DEBATE THATHAT LTOP WAS
RUSSIAN DISINFORMAON.
THAT NOT TRUE.THE FBI, WHO IELIE
DECION.
THE TWITTEMADE
>> Sea DO YOU INK ERE'S
A POIBILITY THAT T
PRESIDENT --
>> THEY HA A LTOP OR THEYKNEW TI
DISINFMATION.
Sean: I'VE GOTO RUN.
>> THE AMERICAN OPLERE GOING
FINOUT  JANRY.
>> Sean:O YOBELIE IT'S
POIBLE JOE BIDENS
MPROSED BY CHINAND RUSSIREAL QC.
>> FR TH HE IS, PECILY
YOU LOOK ATNERGY POLICY
E WOT DE THAT THBIDE
FALY MADE WAS THDEALOULD
TRY  WHERE THEY WERE TRYG TO
HELP CHINA GETHEIROOT THE
OR ON THAMERICAN ENERGINDUSTRYEE
COMPROMISEBECAUSE THE MILLIO
OF DOLLARSE REIVED THROUGH
CHINTH